sein name ist ein synonym für titan der
unternehmen ist ein innovator er ist
eine ikone cher spielt in der gleichen
liga wie die jp morgans die rockefellers
ein pionier der maßgeblich an der
schaffung einer zweieinhalb millionen
dollar schweren industrie beteiligt war
krems hat ständig die grenzen
überschritten die branche des privaten
beteiligungskapitals
mitbestimmt henry war allen voraus wenn
es um geldbeschaffung ging er hat das
geschäft irgendwie erfunden henry kravis
führte einen erbitterten kampf
schockwellen durch die
entscheidung den deal so zu machen wie
er es getan hat das war nicht nur schwer
bewaffnet das war gut für lage aus dem
meer kommt und die wall street entlang
starb er ist ein kämpfer ein
wettbewerbsfähiger kämpfer er hat das
spiel nicht nur verändert er hat es
besser gemacht
[Musik]
henry war an der spitze in den 80er und
wenn man sich henry heute ansieht ist es
die gleiche geschichte
ich hatte keinen zweifel dass der
gewinnt als er sagte er würde diesen
deal gewinnen
vielmehr trifft die großen
entscheidungen gibt den ton an ist seit
jahren derjenige der risiken eingehen
und sie in neue bereiche drängen
henry kravis eröffnete investoren ganz
neue möglichkeiten indem er eine
kriegskasse anhäufte rey die größer ist
als das bruttoinlandsprodukt vieler
kleiner länder bis heute hat er selten
öffentlich über seine arbeit oder sein
leben gesprochen und wollte an unserem
programm nicht teilnehmen
travis wurde 1944 im ölfeld von clsa
oklahoma geboren roma schwarzes gold war
überall sein vater war erdöl ingenieur
der ein vermögen nach
ehemaliger vorsitzender von bear stearns
kennt krems seit über 40 jahren
da war diese große institution in diesem
land die kredite gegen gas oder öl
reserven vergab ohne vorher mit seinem
vater zu sprechen
ist mitautor des wegweisenden
finanzdramas der modernen wirtschaft dem
buch
als man wer einen sehr erfolgreichen
vater hatte wollte er von klein auf
zeigen dass er genau so viel erfolg
haben konnte
travis erfolgsweg führte ihn von der
schule im nordosten nach südkalifornien
im jahr 1963
er studierte wirtschaftswissenschaften
am clemmons mckenna college in einer
eröffnungsrede an seiner alma mater
erzählte er vor kurzem bäume wie das
erwachsenwerden in den 60er jahren
seinen lebensweg geprägt hat es war ja
zehn stürmischer sozialer politischer
wirtschaftlicher und kultureller
veränderungen aber diese schnellen und
aufregenden veränderungen halfen mir zu
sehen wer ich war
ich werden wollte
gravis kehrte ins herz der geschäftswelt
zurück new york nach einem praktikum in
der aktien abteilung einer geld-
verwaltungsfirma drängte ihn sein vater
1967 wieder zur schule zu gehen gehen er
schrieb sich an der columbia business
school ein aber sein fokus lag anderswo
er wollte geschäfte machen er wollte
viel geld verdienen nicht an der
columbia
erst als ein ehemaliger chef ihm
erlaubte in seiner freizeit weiter für
ihn zu arbeiten
ich mache diesen bauern abschluss er
haftet nach dem college nutzte er eine
chance die ein cousin
analyst bei der investment bank
wollte aber nach san francisco kommen
louis eidenberg ist einer ihrer ältesten
freunde
[Musik]
george sind sich mehr als nahe sie
beenden die sätze des anderen sie sind
nicht immer einer meinung aber am ende
kommen sie zu den gleichen
schlussfolgerungen und sie sind
gleichermaßen brillant in diesem
geschäft
trotz der über 3.000 meilen zwischen
ihnen arbeiteten sie im selben team mit
ihrem chef einem finanz visionär
henrys timing war erstaunlich er gerät
an einen job mit seinem kollegen jerry
kolberg der diese seltsamen geschäfte
machte von denen noch nie jemand gehört
hatte
wie andere investmentbanker nicht sahen
leveraged buy out mbo sind ganz einfach
ein unternehmen kauft sich selbst du
nimmst einen großteil ihres überschusses
weg macht sie schön klein
dienstleistende menge geld und um das
zurückzuzahlen verkaufst du dann die
vermögenswerte er hatte die idee auf
familienunternehmen zu zielen menschen
die in rente gehen wollten wollten sich
nicht unbedingt der lehre konkurrenz
verkaufen für menschen die sich große
sorgen um die leute machten die für sie
arbeiten wenn idee begann sich
auszuzahlen die übernahme des industrie
tyler unternehmens in cham international
92 millionen dollar brachte den höchsten
preis ein den gravis hier gesehen hat
950.000 dollar
innerhalb von drei jahren machte gravis
seine eigenen geschäfte und wurde mit 30
jahren partner von gestern
wenn ein bio funktionieren soll darfst
du keine spur von sentimentalität zeigen
muss zerfetzen und verbrennen kann
henrys fähigkeiten dafür waren ideal ist
sehr versiert nüchtern und analytisch
zögert keine sekunde an den manager zu
feuern der seine zahlen nicht lieben
aber
den doch lb oz haben ein langes echo in
der schnellen profit kultur von bear
stearns
zu sagen sie hatten keine geduld mit
jerry steals ist als würde man sagen
dass es in texas im sommer heiß wird es
war eine frage der zeit
die spitze von bear stearns lehnte
kolberg forderung ab eine eigene
abteilung zu gründen
die drei männer stellten schnell fest
dass ihre zeit bei der legendären
investmentbank vorbei war es ging mir
nicht gut damit ich habe oft gesagt ich
glaube wir haben nicht hart genug daran
gearbeitet sie alle am laufen zu halten
ich habe es immer bereut es war
schwierig wie solche schritte halt sind
harry henry stellt viele fragen auch
sich selbst aber er lässt dann seien
entscheidungen sehr wenig selbst zweifel
erkennen
und ihr mentor jerry kolberg ein großes
risiko ein
verbittert verließen sie das wall street
haus passt
wir werden unsere eigene firma gründen
und uns auf etwas konzentrieren das noch
nie zuvor gemacht wurde wir nennen es
die boots trap akquisition ist ich will
das wirklich machen mit george wir
werden es versuchen
nur bewaffnet mit ihrer neuartigen idee
geld zu verdienen und 400.000 dollar von
unterstützern ging am ersten mai wall
street neuestes private equity
unternehmen kkr investments an den start
durch travis musste potenzielle
investoren und elbow ziele sofort davon
überzeugen werden dass er hohe renditen
erzielen kann
seit anfang der 70er jahre kravitz
berater die meisten leute würden sagen
was wie hoch wollen sie diese firma
belasten wie willst du das machen wo mit
verweis auf seine erfolge bei der stars
überzeugte er investoren ihr geld zu
geben james robinson ehemaliger
vorsitzender von american express bis
seit über 30 jahren mit gravis
befreundet
ich habe diesen aufgeweckten jungen
burschen kennengelernt er war wirklich
ein sehr kluger investmentbanker der
eine neue richtung einschlagen wollte
das war spannend
eine neue art die wall street zu nutzen
kapital zu mobilisieren um in
unternehmen zu investieren um sie noch
stärker zu machen von der renten welt
bis hin zu anderen war daran
interessiert sind teilhaber zu werden
henry und sein cousin george suchten
nach unternehmen mit vorhersehbaren
cashflow und wachstumspotenzial ihr
ansatz war mit dem bestehenden
management zusammen zu arbeiten für
einen reibungslosen übergang
john mac ist vorstandsvorsitzender von
morgan stanley hat kennt henry kravis
seit fast 20 jahren
er ist hervorragend dar in einem
vorstand seine geschichte seine vision
zu verkaufen
er wirkt so als wüsste er
kennt die fahrbahn erlegt da was er sich
vorstellt was er denkt warum er das
denkt und was das ergebnis sein wird
ist ein gewicht mit dem man bei einem
dealer rechnen muss und man erkennt
seine emotionen darin
1979 machte er seinen ersten grossen
deal mit dem autoteile hersteller
hyundai industries damals der erste bau
eines großen börsennotierten
unternehmens in der geschichte der wall
street
work & roberts aber nur der erste von
481 82 83 waren tolle jahre hier gaben
ihnen glaubwürdigkeit am markt gaben
ihnen glaubwürdigkeit bei banken und
versicherungen die 20 prozentige
beteiligung an jedem geschäft machte
gravis 1983 zu einem multi millionär im
selben jahr schuf kkr einen
rekordverdächtigen investmentfonds eine
milliarde dollar um die konkurrenz
einzuschüchtern es war eine eher an die
später im film wall street in einer
berühmt einfachen zeit zusammengefasst
wurde
hier mangels eines besseren wortes ist
gut
und es ging gerade erst los der 1984
waren kredite leichter zu bekommen
risikoreiche junk bonds mit niedrigem
rating wurden zum entscheidenden motor
für ihre lb aus
[Musik]
junk bonds konnte man einfach so
bekommen wichtig war die geschwindigkeit
sie machte es händlern george möglich
über macht eine finanzierung zu finden
damit ein deal funktioniert
mit neuen angeboten kamen auch die
einladungen zum glamourösen
veranstaltungen in new york travis
zweite ehe mit der aufstrebenden
modedesignerin coraline
katapultierte sie auf die
hochglanzseiten
bekommen sie erschienen oft mit ihrem
guten freund
henry war damals eine sehr glamouröse
figur er war ein sehr einfacher kerl mit
einem brillanten verstand aber er war
auch irgendwie immer von glamour umgeben
travis war jetzt eine betuchte säule der
sozialen elite von new york
henry hatte keine ahnung was die
partnerschaft mit coraline und die
auftritte in den sozialen kolumnen
bringen würden die welt guckte zu und
sie sah einen reichen mann sie sahen
überfluss und diese dinge wurden zum
symbol der 80 henry wurde zum symbol der
80er er hasste haste hasste es
1985 verkörperte
war das erfolgreichste leveraged buy-out
unternehmen der welt und verwaltete
einen investmentfonds im wert von einer
milliarde dollar und mit dem erfolg
kamen nachahmer
der wettbewerb hat eine völlig neue welt
geschaffen sie kommen sich nicht mehr
zurück lehnen und den white plains
pfeife rauchen er plötzlich mussten
geschäfte schneller erledigt werden
sonst würde das jemand anderes turnier
zum ersten mal gelenkten henry und
george takei zu unfreundlichen deals
unfreundliche deals wie mit beatrice dem
mutterkonzern einiger der bekanntesten
marken amerika ist
1986 übernahm sie den riesenkonzern für
6,2 milliarden dollar aus und stellten
damit erneut einen rekord an der wall
street auf
verschwendete keine zeit damit beatrice
stückchenweise zu verkaufen um die
schulden zu begleichen damit
davis und sein cousin verdienten 5 und
die hohen honorare und gewinner wie sie
führten zu einer spaltung innerhalb von
gravis und sein mentor jerry kolberg
kämpften und die seele ihres
unternehmens im mai 87 verließ kolberg
hätten
gegenüber der new york times sprach er
von einem verfall der ethik und dass er
an geschäften festhalten wolle bei denen
noch die vernunft vorherrscht
war für alle drei sehr schmerzlich für
alle war es sehr traurig dass pearl
quasi von dem von ihnen gegründeten
geschäft abgeschoben wurde allerdings
hatten henry und george danach ganz klar
die kontrolle
kravis & roberts waren genau dort wo sie
sein wollen aber mit beatrice fuß
schießen sie schnell auf neuen ärger
nachdem kaka die meisten vermögenswerte
abgebaut hatte um die schulden zu
begleichen war da immer noch die
aufgeblähte lebensmittelabteilung des
unternehmens
gravis hungerte nach einem neuen
blockbuster
1987 fand er den perfekten
übernahmekandidaten das unternehmen
eine der größten aktiengesellschaften
der usa der aktienkurs lag bei 40 dollar
und sollte sich bald als unterbewertet
besaß zwei riesige unternehmen ob ein
käufer könnten abisko verkaufen auf und
die äußerst profitablen zigarettenmarken
winston und
sie haben süchtige kunden am himmelsberg
sie machen tonnenweise geld jeder wollte
diesen deal machen und sie hatten einen
vorstand der sich fast alles anhört was
johnson war sehr sehr groß er liebte es
jemandem ein flugzeug zur verfügung zu
stellen um zu einem golfturnier zu gehen
manchmal hat er vielleicht zu viele
dinge mit einer bis groß vermögen
gemacht aber er meinte es gut frost
johnson musste den stagnierenden
aktienkurs eines unternehmens wieder
ankurbeln nach dem crash am schwarzen
montag 1987 und den problemen mit einem
neuen produkt da war diese raus lose zu
gerettet
nach jahren der herstellung landete es
mit einem gewaltigen plumps auf den mann
nicht
möchte eine privatisierung über einen
elbow war seine chance das unternehmen
wieder zu beleben und ein persönliches
vermögen zu machen die bühne war bereits
travis war ein jahr zuvor mit dieser
idee an johnson herangetreten wo aber es
gab ein problem was würde ihnen schwer
fallen zwei unternehmensleiter zu finden
die sich so stark unterscheiden wie
credit & johnson kontrolliert und ernst
voss alles andere als das er trägt eine
kleine halskette wissen sie es
es war klar dass die beiden sich in die
haare kriegen johnson und sein
managementteam beschlossen sich
selbstständig zu machen und mit schießen
liemen zusammenzuarbeiten bei einer
investmentbank ohne cache erfahrung mit
bios und zwanzigster oktober 88 machten
sie einen vorschlag
sie boten 75 dollar pro aktie fast 20
mehr als der aktienkurs
der krieg hatte begonnen
er war zu diesem zeitpunkt der könig in
diesem geschäft und
er war persönlich beleidigt dass eine
gruppe kleiner nobodys immer bio
geschäft dachten sie könnten in sein
revier kommen und den größten deal
durchziehen der jemals vorgeschlagen
wurde johnsons gruppe versuchte mit
gravis frieden zu schließen das brachte
nichts nur vier tage später shoppen
gravis und kaká die finanzwelt mit einem
eigenen angebot bis 20 milliarden dollar
also 90 dollar pro aktie
entscheidung den deal so einzugehen wie
er es getan hat das waren nicht nur
große waffen das war gut zähler der aus
dem meer kam und die wall street entlang
stoppte er woll für potenzielle käufer
abschrecken
der muttergesellschaft von jason lee
mann war auf der anderen seite des songs
wenn henry und george persönlichen
geschäfte verwickelt sind dann wissen
sie dass sie es mit einem sehr fähigen
gegner zu tun haben bei der ergo
vorstand lehnte das angebot von pa ab
obwohl johnson von henry kravis
aggressiven angriffe überrumpelt wurde
wer nicht nach und konterte mit einem
weiteren angebot von 92 dollar pro aktie
knapp 29 milliarden dollar
es war wie bei zwei revolverhelden auf
der straße jeder baut in zu gucken oder
jeder wollte sich eine waffe schnappen
die medien lieben kämpfen sie lieben
krieg sie lieben sieger und sie leben
verlierer
die rund um die uhr berichterstattung
über den größten deal der geschichte
gefielen krems gar nicht
niemand mag es wenn sein team tagtäglich
in der presse verhandelt und dabei
komplett übertrieben wird wenn du so ein
spiel spielst dann schießen die leute
auch erb sie greifen durchfahren muss
lernen eine dicke haut zu haben
der alte vorstand lehnte auch johnsons
vorschlag ab seite jedoch allen
potenziellen bietern mit dass sie zehn
tage zeit haben nun ein weiteres angebot
zu unterbreiten die konfrontation
zwischen den bietern
[Musik]
ich glaube henry würde ihnen heute sagen
dass ein teil dessen was ihn unbewusst
antrieb der wunsch war zu gewinnen das
einzige todsünde die man im akquisitions
geschäfte gehen kann ist
sechs wochen nach dem ersten angebot
waren kravis & roberts in einer lasten
manage bietungsgruppe verwickelt
ihr lasst das gebot unglaubliche 109
dollar pro aktie fast das doppelte des
ursprünglichen preises
jetzt hieß es warten liegen die
anspannung war groß alle waren müde
ich erinnere mich dass es sehr spät in
der nacht war als endlich die
entscheidung fiel
alles vorbei es ist alles vorbei am 29
november 88 kurz nach zehn uhr abends
hatte der vorstand von ada seine
entscheidung getroffen
wir sind die besten in der branche sie
wissen was sie tun
jonsson versuchte den grössten insider
job der geschichte zu konstruieren hätte
mindestens 100 millionen dollar verdient
wenn der deal funktioniert hätte
aber ein wall street view namens henry
travis schnappte ihm die firma
johnson
ikea machte 75 millionen dollar an
gebühren
der klare sieg brachte handy zum gipfel
seines coups an der wall street aber
mehr als alles andere was sich aus den
gesprächen mit ihm weiß war so dass sie
vor allem angst hatten fiel das nicht zu
schaffen letztendlich erwiesen sich
diese befürchtungen als begründet
[Musik]
der gewinner im epischen geschäfts kampf
aber
für henry kravis war die freude nur von
kurzer dauer
[Musik]
sie hatten gewonnen aber langfristig
zahlte es sich nicht so aus wie sie es
sich erhofft hatten haupt die folgen des
mega deals waren katastrophal es hatte
nicht perfekt funktioniert und der druck
war groß diese sache hinzukriegen und
für die investoren eine rendite zu
erzählen der firma wird oft zu einer
großen übernahme gratuliert aber er hat
immer gesagt sprachen sie sich dass wir
später auf gratulieren sie mir wenn wir
da rauskommen in 99 die 1991 erlebte
crêpes ist eine familien travis face of
fame the tragedy harrison sein 19
jähriger sohn aus einer früheren ehe kam
bei einem autounfall ums leben
sein leben war nicht einfach sein
privatleben war tragisch sind seinen
sohn zu verlieren
kann man sich nicht wirklich vorstellen
zwei jahre später war travis in der
boulevardpresse als er sich nach sieben
jahren von seiner frau carol ein raum
schreiten ließ
er heiratete erneut marie-josée drohe
eine bekannte ökonomen und philanthropen
1995 machten zigaretten preiskriege die
gewinne von alt zunächst
die jährliche rendite sank auf weniger
als ein prozent
entschied dass es sich nicht mehr lohnte
an den konzernriesen festzuhalten sie
stießen die investition ab und einer der
berühmtesten schlachten der wall street
ging zu ende
sie haben gefragt hat der ac a d der
beste an der wall street war ich glaube
als sternstunde würde ihnen niemand
bezeichnen sondern vielleicht eher als
schlimmste stunde die eher niedrigen
zustande eine stunde in der all die
dinge die
stereotypen an die die menschen glauben
dass es an der wall street nur um ego
und gier
dass sich diese dinge am ende alle als
wahr erwiesen
nach einigen schwierigen deals in den
90ern hatten krems um kkr zu kämpfen
2001 ging eine ihrer beteiligungen
riegel cinemas bankrotts was sie eine
halbe milliarde dollar kostete
angeschlagen aber ungebeugt gab gravis
zu dass sie ihre geschäftsabläufe ändern
mussten und nach jahren des
wiederaufbaus machten sie erneut
schlagzeilen
in 2006 kauften sie die krankenhauskette
apps im wert von 33 milliarden dollar
jason kidd equity reporter
[Musik]
und tat es noch mal mit dem thema exil
im jahr 2007 sie kamen zurück bekamen
heftig zurück 2007 begann sie zu
versuchen das unternehmen unter new
yorker börse zu notieren
2010 gab es dann schließlich ein
enttäuschendes debüt ein börsengang ist
für diese jungs eine außerordentlich
schwierige entscheidung für diese firma
die er und georgia über die jahre
aufgebaut haben ist vor allem unbequem
der öffentlichkeit alle geheimnisse
offenzulegen
das portfolio umfasst 58 unternehmen m
und verwaltet ein vermögen von über 55
milliarden dollar
aber selbst das deck nicht die ganze
breite ab
218 milliarden dollar umsatz aller
unternehmen die sie besitzen kampf und
spielwaren händlern über
stromproduzenten texas
es gibt zwei arten von typen an der
wallstreet denjenigen der sich nach
florida zurück zieht und denjenigen das
nicht zu für ihn ist sein vermächtnis
das wichtigste ich glaube nicht dass
immer erwartet wird dass man ständig
alle rekorde bricht aber wenn es einen
ort gibt an dem das möglich ist dann
wird er bei kk ein starkes team
zusammenstellen und sie werden jede
menge rekorde brechen
wenn sie an den glauben und einen traum
haben dann folgen sie ihm egal was
passiert
er ist ein innovator er ist eine ikone
er spielt in der gleichen liga wie die
jp morgan
henry ist ein großartiger typ mit einem
unglaublichen instinkt für das was in
der zukunft passieren wird er kann es
besser sehen als fast jeder andere und
das ist eine furchtbar gute eigenschaft
wenn es ums geschäft geht
[Musik]